[Music]
once everything was awesome
now everything is okay Lucy I brought
you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh Ness
did I interrupt you brooding just now
times have changed
you need to change with them we have to
be tough and battle-ready
[Music]
oh the pain it's Jane so cold
see that wasn't so bad nothing got in
this is all my fault
hang on to your fronds planet we're
going you mind if I save your life not
at all who are you names Rex danger vest
galaxy defending archaeologist cowboy
Raptor trainer I don't get it we'll help
me rescue my friends you don't want to
go anywhere near the sistar system it's
ruled by an alien coin only the toughest
you're gonna get out of there alive I'm
the queen whatever I would not be I'm
getting super evil vibes here I could
change my form to something else if this
makes you uncomfortable hey guys they'll
go back don't horse was much more
palatable
[Music]
did you draw double dots on your face
No
who are you I'm your worst nightmare
Oh me when I'm late to school and I
forgot my homework and my pants are made
of pudding no I don't
[Music]
you